a somber salute from Canadian troops as
four busloads of Ukrainian forces head
home from this British military training
camp these soldiers that come through
here are fighting for their freedom
their Homeland their families and their
future and it is a absolute privilege to
be a part of that process and help them
to do that 170 Canadian soldiers have
been based at this camp for the past
year and have trained 2600 ukrainians
part of Canada's operation unifier to
help build Ukraine's military capacity
the majority of ukrainians who come here
were until recently civilians and after
a five-week intensive training program
go home to Ukraine to fight in a war
we just need to push the enemy from our
land these bastards Grizzly is a
Furniture maker and is married with two
kids he never held a gun before coming
here
I really really enjoyed being here
especially Canadian structures they're
tough but still I do enjoy like working
training with them as part of his visit
to Europe Canada's defense minister Bill
Blair stopped by for the salute and to
meet the Canadian trainers the training
that's being provided here I believe in
the evidence that the ukraines have
provided us is is actually saving lives
it's helping them be far more effective
in in their military response to Russian
aggression Blair also announced that
some of Canada's previously pledged
financing to Ukraine will go toward air
defense systems my perception is that
Canadians overwhelmingly understand
not unanimously but but I think very
very over overwhelmingly there's a
strong consensus of our responsibility
to support Ukraine Canada has pledged
more than 8 billion dollars in Aid and
Military assistance to Ukraine since the
start of Russia's full invasion but it
is many of the these new recruits who
will pay the ultimate price Redmond
Shannon Global News in the southeast of
England